[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
the oscar nominations are in
did i scare you i'm sorry bolstered by
four acting nominations for benedict
cumberbatch kirsten dunst cody smith
mcphee and jesse plemons the power of
the dog led the way with 12 nominations
not far behind was doomed with 10
nominations including just about every
technical category but surprisingly
there was no nomination for best
director denis velanov did receive two
nominations however for best picture and
best adapted screenplay and he's
currently hard at work on dune part 2
maybe the academy is taking a wait and
see approach like lord of the rings
fandango completed a survey on the
morning that nominations were announced
and found that fandango users are
rooting for dune and best picture and
kanto for best animated feature and
steven spielberg for best director for
west side story
however our poll also found that 32
percent of those surveyed still need to
see four or more of the best picture
nominees
but you're in luck because many of them
are available in the forth coming weeks
or right now on voodoo check out the
description below for all the academy
award nominations and a link to voodoo's
award season front runners and let us
know which movies and performances that
you're rooting for for example if the
mitchells in the machines doesn't win
best animated feature
i'll probably just watch the movie again
how about we put our phones down and we
can make 10 seconds of unobstructed
family eye contact starting now
see this is good right here this is
natural well spider-man no way home
didn't come away with a best picture
nomination to go along with being one of
the highest grossing movies of all time
sony continues to build on its spidey
adjacent universe
last week it was announced that dakota
johnson would take on madame webb and
this week we got a little more news
about an introductory movie for one of
spider-man's most famous villains craven
the hunter
as craven aaron taylor johnson will be
joined by oscar winner russell crowe in
an unknown familiar role to the hunter
both actors are no stranger to comic
book movies as taylor johnson previously
played quicksilver and avengers age of
ultron whereas crow not only played
superman's biological father and man of
steel but he's also set to appear as
zeus in thor love and thunder later this
year michael mann the acclaimed director
of heat finally has some good news on
this two-decade passion project of his
not only does he have a cast set in
place for his enzo ferrari biopic but he
also has distribution with stx coming on
board
set during the summer of 1957 adam
driver will play enzo ferrari bankruptcy
looms over the company he and his wife
built from nothing 10 years earlier so
he decides to counter his losses by
rolling the dice on one race
one thousand miles across italy birthing
the iconic miley milia penelope cruz and
shailene woodley co-star and man and
crew will finally put rubber to the road
when production starts in italy this may
after spider-man no way home led the box
office for seven of its first eight
weeks of release tom holland is swinging
back into theaters as a young nathan
drake in uncharted
my dude loves swinging uncharted is an
adaptation of the popular adventure
video game series in the film adaptation
tom holland's nathan drake is recruited
by seasoned treasure hunter victor sully
sullivan played by mark wahlberg to
recover a fortune amassed by ferdinand
magellan which was lost 500 years ago if
nate and sully can decipher the clues
and solve one of the world's oldest
mysteries they stand to collect 5
billion dollars worth of treasure but
only if they can learn to work together
fandango correspondent naz perez
recently sat down with holland and
wahlberg to talk about the big action
set pieces particularly one involving
nathan and sully maneuvering around
cargo boxes that tumble out of an
airplane mid-flight i had to train a lot
and i got as strong as i've ever been
but the interesting thing is uh
i basically wanted to put on as much
size as possible you know because next
to mark wahlberg i look like a rake so i
wanted to just get into shape and put on
as much weight as possible but in doing
that you know i didn't do any
cardiovascular
work because i didn't want to burn any
unnecessary calories in the gym meaning
that when we were shooting these long
sequences i was so unfit
like you'd ask me to run a mile and i
would have collapsed so it was tough it
was a sort of double-edged sword of like
i could do pull-ups for days but if you
ask me to run a mile i'd fall apart oh
my god and what was it like shooting it
like did you come out unscathed because
it just looks so
physically intense
i mean there were there were times where
you know we ripped our hands to
smithereens you know like hanging onto
those boxes and eventually your grip
strength would give out and you would
just let go and upon letting go you'd
have rope burn and blisters and bangs
and bruises you know i unfortunately i
kicked a poor stuntman in the face in
that sequence he was okay he is an
ex-ufc fighter so he's tough as nails
that doesn't excuse
my
lack of judgment uh but just the way the
wire work had worked out i was closer to
him than usual and i booted him in the
face but he was okay which was good to
know uh so there's a lot of blood sweat
and tears that went into that sequence
so i was wondering did you get to do
anything in uncharted that you hadn't
done before in a movie um yeah i mean i
probably i've because i've done so much
i've probably done it all but it was the
first time that i just felt like i was
in a big movie like this felt like
indiana jones where you're transported
into a world and you're seeing something
that you're just normally not privy to
seeing that's why it always just felt
like that you know i've done these
little intimate movies i've done many
different kinds of films but this is the
first big like action adventure
blockbuster that takes you on this
magical mystical ride that is full of
adventure and joy it really is like
you're literally on your like at the
edge of your seat until the very end
right after i right after i read i
literally watched every one of the
indiana joneses and then i watched you
know romancing the stone and other
movies that i felt like had some sort of
similarities
this weekend's new theatrical releases
are uncharted and dog heck no no no
no you're just a demon you're just a
demon and dog channing tatum's
directorial debut tatum plays an army
ranger looking to get back into
deployment to show his mental fitness
he's tasked with escorting a trained
military dog named lulu down the pacific
coast in hopes of making it to a fellow
soldier's funeral on time along the way
they drive each other completely crazy
break a handful of laws narrowly evade
death and learn to let down their guards
in order to have a fighting chance of
finding happiness
and available to watch at home this
weekend are parallel mothers and the
king's man
this will not be
a war of heroes
which is all to see
this is going to be fun ray finds stars
in a prequel to the first two kingsman
films the king's man matthew vaughn
continues to mix his adult cocktail of
globetrotting espionage this time with a
dash of the real life mystical figure
rasputin played by rhys iphones gemma
archerton harrison dickinson and jaime
honsu costa amongst the comic violence
that the trilogy is known for
alright well that's it for this week but
before you go let us know which
oscar-nominated movies you need to catch
up on
all right i'm kale and i'll see you next
week i will let you go i promise
we don't pay her enough
[Music]
you